découvrez-en icinéma haïti je m'appelle
mccree gars je dirige cette entreprise
laissez-moi vous montrer le futur ça
devienne plainte et trouvera
l'intérimaire merci pour le climat ce
serait pas mal que vous passiez chez moi
pour voir notre internet est porteur
madame l'informaticien
j'imagine que vous savez que les
panneaux intelligente de la maison ont
des caméras intégrées
jésus est désactivé je tiens à ma vie
privée sur make it in may ouvriérisme us
nous sommes entre amis bonne nuit alors
c'était qui personne j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle on a été piraté j attends de
voir la gueule que tu feras kanté de
[ __ ] d'avions vont se mettre un tombé
du ciel
donc on n'a pas nettoyé le système aucun
avion ne décolle avec vos des preuves
pour étayer une accusation aussi grave
les mots de passe les codes protéger cet
endroit
la vie privée n'existe pas
je veux petit but face à des problèmes
c'est un homme au reporter
haïti le 10 novembre au cinéma siro
service de vidéo à la demande
exclusivement chez vous